Just because we found methane on Mars doesn’t
mean there are cattle farms on the red planet.
Hey guys, Amy here for DNews.
In the ongoing and imagination-capturing search
for life on other planets, methane is one
of the gases that gets people really excited.
Methane is an extremely simple molecule made
of one carbon atom surrounded by four hydrogen
atoms.
It’s one of the greenhouse gases that exists
in trace amounts in our atmosphere, and it’s
created in oxygen-free processes in biological
organisms.
A couple of examples: Archaebacteria release
the greenhouse gas in rice fields, and most
famously (or infamously, perhaps) cows release
methane through flatulence… they fart it
out.
Biological production of methane accounts
for most of the gas’ existence on our planet,
so it stands to reason that finding methane
on Mars would imply that there’s some organism
producing it on that planet as well.
Except that there are other ways to produce
methane without biological processes.
Methane can come from rocks.
It’s possible for ancient methane to be
released from water-formed inclusions and
cavities in basalt, a type of rock that is
extremely common on Mars.
Basalt can incorporate methane through both
biological and geological processes, like
the process that turns olivine into serpentinites,
a type of rock composed of serpentine minerals.
That methane can be released when the rock
is broken apart, like when it’s drilled
into, and found using spectroscopy.
And we’ve actually found traces of Methane
on Mars before, granted, a few of those times
it was in air delivered to Mars trapped in
an instrument, so we were actually detecting
Earth methane.
The methane we’ve detected on Mars in the
past has been fairly widely distributed over
the planet in patches that vary over time
suggesting that the gas is released from subsurface
stores and is destroyed pretty quickly.
On Mars where the atmosphere is thin, heavily
composed of carbon dioxide, and where there’s
no magnetic field to protect the gases in
the atmosphere, methane lasts only months
compared to the 300-plus year lifetime it
has on Earth.
The other part of the puzzle is the low amount
of methane on Mars compared to Earth; the
recent spike Curiosity found peaked at 7 parts
per billion.
On Earth, we’ve got about 1,600 parts per
billion of methane.
It’s very possible that the production and
level of methane on Mars is so low to be negligible
on Earth but are exciting on Mars because
it’s all we have.
It could be something awesome, but it could
also be nothing.
Are you guys on team something exciting to
come from methane on Mars?
Let us know in the comments below or you can
catch me on Twitter as @astVintageSpace.
And don’t forget to subscribe for more DNews
every day of the week.